Das panel könnte im jahr 2000
167 auf die erde stürzen die folgen wären fatal
konkrete details über bänder sind uns bislang nicht bekannt doch das könnte sich schon bald ändern denn derzeit geht die mission um die raumsonde
osiris rex nach zwei jahren
anreise in die heiße phase jetzt mitte august sollen die ersten bilder geschossen werden und im dezember soll dann die ernährungs phase erfolgreich
abgeschlossen sein dann wird die sonde auf dem asteroiden landen und proben mit zur erde bringen wie die mission genau geplant ist was die proben
des astro ihnen über ihn verraten können und wie so ein möglicher asteroideneinschlag eben gut
150 jahren verhindert werden soll jetzt bei klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Ihr könnt jetzt übrigens
mitglied hierbei klicks um auf youtube werden dafür gibt es einen extra video einen privat livestream nur für euch und noch ein paar
privilegien wie zum beispiel extra images dafür habe ich mich ziemlich ins zeug gelegt aber
dazu am ende des videos mehr um es mal direkt auf den punkt zu bringen
einem asteroideneinschlag sind wir genau wie das restliche leben auf der erde
einfach nur schutzlos ausgeliefert ihr könnt euch alle ausmalen was bei einem arzt zu ihnen anschlag auf der erde passieren könnte holly und filme
dazu gibt es ja genug fliegende trümmer tsunami wellen und schlimme erdbeben etwa könnten einen großteil des lebens auf der erde auslöschen
den riesen brocken benno ideen zählt die nasa zu den gefährlichsten aller bekannten asteroiden
berechnungen zufolge könnte er bei einem vorbeiflug am 25 september
2001 135 der erde tatsächlich
gefährlich nahe kommen näher
als der erde und das wiederum könnte seine weitere flugbahn so verändern dass er noch im selben jahr 100 mit der erde kollidiert
dazu der forscher patrick mittel vom pariser observatorium
wenn s bahn haben wir bis ins jahr
vorausberechnet dann wird er sich der erde bis auf ungefähr
280 1000 kilometer annähern
danach ist ein weiterer kurs unsicher da er davon abhängt wie nah er der erde wirklich kommt und wie stark sie seine bahn
verändert unseren analysen zufolge könnte er beim nächsten mal im jahr 2001
67 mit einer wahrscheinlichkeit von 1 zu
2700 auf der erde einschlagen
eine studie aus 2009 berechnete eine serie von möglichen zusammenstößen mit der erde zwischen 2169 und 2199
doch die genaue wahrscheinlichkeit für eine kollision ist wie gesagt nicht wirklich zu beziffern denn die
physikalischen eigenschaften des asteroiden sind noch weitestgehend unbekannt
eine version mit bühne hätte mit seinem durchmesser von 500 metern und einem gewicht von
87 millionen tonnen jedenfalls fatale folgen bei einem aufprall würde er nach berechnungen der nasa wohl eine energie von
80.000 atombomben freisetzen das entspricht einer kinetischen energie von
1200 megatonnen und schreiben also nur 100 jahre um gegenmaßnahmen für diesen möglichen asteroideneinschlag zu erarbeiten
wir hatten in diesem zusammenhang der bereits über die idee der nasa werde planetary die fans team berichtet
stichwort hemmer das steht für high velocity
sj mitigation mission for emergency response
wege ein neun meter langes und knapp neun tonnen
schweres raumschiff das mit einer delta 4 mw in den weltraum gebracht werden soll es könnte nicht nur als transportmittel
für eine atombombe dienen sondern auch als rammbock
beispielsweise eben für bennet denn ein kleiner schubs sagt könnte den asteroiden zu einer kursänderung bringen doch das ist nicht die einzige
strategie an der forschungsteams weltweit tüfteln um uns verbindet zu schützen
denn derzeit wird es auch um die raumsonde osiris rex die auf dem asteroiden benny landen soll extrem spannend jetzt soll sich die sonne so
angenähert haben das erste fotos gemacht werden können und auch sonst sind die erwartungen an die mission alles andere als klein
astronomie teams hoffen auf überlebenswichtige erkenntnisse für die menschheit dazu
alexander may ingenieur bei lockheed martin space systems company die die sonde im auftrag der nasa gebaut hat
es haben bereits einige untersuchungen des asteroiden aus der ferne stattgefunden werden ihn sowohl mit rada als auch mit optischen
teleskope von der erde aus beobachtet
unsere wissenschaftler haben einige vermutungen woraus das objekt besteht und wie groß das genau ist wir glauben wenn er ist der perfekte ort
um eine proben enden arme durchzuführen der plan sieht vor zunächst die geologische
zusammensetzung von bennett zu untersuchen um zu wissen wie porös und kompakt der brocken wirklich ist die annäherung an den riesen brocken soll so
vorsichtig wie möglich passieren dann wird das erste wissenschaftliche instrument eingesetzt die politik hat die aufgabe
pendelzug kartografiert theoretisch ist die kamera in der lage objekte in der größe eines
kieselstein zu erfassen im dezember soll die sonde dann so nahe bei dem asteroiden sein dass seine schwerkraft gegen die anziehungskraft der sonne
gewinnt osirix 6 wird dann in eine umlaufbahn von benny
einschwenken die sonde soll sich dann auch auf das schwerefeld des asteroiden genauer anschauen
besteht der brocken er aus gestein oder ist er ein objekt das sich aus losem und porösem material mit viel staub
zusammensetzt auch das ist eine info die für das leben auf der erde im ernstfall von immenser bedeutung
sein könnte doch auch andere super spannende erkenntnisse könnte uns die probe von ben bescheren dazu osiris rex forscher umberto kamp ins
diese primitiven hast du jeden verfügen über einen hohen anteil organischer moleküle
wenn wir verstehen wollen wie das leben auf der erde und vielleicht anderswo entstanden ist müssen wir die
zusammensetzung solche asteroiden
verstehen die probenentnahme selbst ist allerdings erst für in zwei
jahren geplant dann steht der rückflug zur erde an und der dauert wohl bis
2023 und das neueste ihr könnt mitglied hier auf dem kanal werden und neben ein paar
privilegien gibt es dann nur für euch exklusiv an extra video und einen
privat
livestream einfach
auf mitglied werden hier unter dem video klicken wenn ihr kein video zum thema soliden anschläge und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann hättet
mich bei whatsapp dann umgeht er die etwas unzuverlässige abo boxer auf youtube und er verpasst kein video weil ihr dort vorab
garantiert informiert werdet einfach hier draufklicken und am besten auch mal ein schwesterkanal krieg zum social media abonnieren dafür ihr klicken aber nicht die
genau die glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken gefährlichster akteur
nasa rammbock gegen benno bis dann
bleibt dran